but uh yeah how have you what have you
guys been up to something's been on my
mind gentlemen i want to ask you because
i was thinking about this last night i
was turning over my bed wondering just
really oh jesus
i was like i was like do i have a weird
opinion on this or not so do you read
fan mail
no no because like a lot of fan mail i
get is just sometimes you get really
weird fan mail and my my like we have
geeks plus for a reason right it's the
filter out of the like the
uh are you talking like physical family
are you talking like emails both both
okay well i read physical letters
obviously yeah but like you have
physical letters well sometimes i do
yeah how do you get physical letters how
do they know what to set it to i don't
know they just send it to geek spot
oh god well like even like back you know
during like the convention days and
stuff like that like you know if it's
hand written right then of course i'm
going to take the time to read it
because you know they put some time into
it anyone can write up an email in five
seconds right so it's like you know
emails it's different story if it's more
than like two paragraphs then i'll read
it yeah just to see what's going you
know i was thinking about this because i
i remember this whole thing that
happened a long time ago with this
youtuber i knew and it was this whole
stupid drama and uh you know one of the
points that this uh guy proud uh prided
himself on was the fact that he
responded to every single fan mail he
um
now when you hear that as a viewer
you're probably thinking that's amazing
one of the amazing guys that's great as
a youtuber when i hear that i'm like oh
he's a psychopath yeah right that guy's
bad news
that sounds so bad as a viewer i know
but this is like this is honestly one
that's honest to god it is like if
you're a youtuber you know that it
depends on how big he is right because
you reach a point as a youtuber where
you're like i'm gonna reply to every
comment and be thankful i'm gonna read
all the comments yeah which like
obviously we're thankful to our viewers
but you get past the point where it
becomes unmanageable yeah yeah to like
respond to everyone yeah which is why
it's like the thing of you know i'm not
saying that oh you can't check them you
can check yeah right but like people who
are so proud about the fact that they
keep up with so much of it it's like you
know you have to wonder you're like that
isn't healthy for anyone keeping up with
that amount of no well i mean let's just
be honest i mean most of it's praise
right yeah and i feel like when someone
is so into hearing about you know oh god
i love reading all these letters of
people thanking me i'm like yeah
you're just a massive narcissist
at the end of the day what you like
reading is you like reading hundreds and
hundreds of letters of people saying how
amazing you are yeah or how much they
like your stuff and i'm like you know
it's like i guess you know
self-confidence aside right like it gets
to a point where it's like
um
even when i got like loads of physical
letters like there was only so many i
could read in a day before i got like i
felt like i was doing a disservice to
the letters by just reading them all in
a sequence because i'm like all right
now i'm now i'm doing what my human
brain does and just spotting patterns
and i'm spotting patterns between the
letters that i yeah and i'm forming a uh
number right yeah you do and i i don't
like the fact that it kind of ruins
female for you that you read it so much
i agree with that yeah but i was having
this thought and i'm like i was i was
thinking about it and i'm like ah i
don't think i've ever seen youtubers who
are like i don't [ __ ] read any of my
fan mail i don't read any of my fan mail
or anything like that because people are
scared to say it yeah but i guarantee 90
of the youtubers out there
don't read the fan mail i know it sounds
bad
this is one of those topics that i love
this is why i like trash taste because
we can talk about this right and we can
try kind of come at it from an angle
where can kind of explain it in a way
where it's like i hope that i don't come
off as the [ __ ] right because it
certainly sounds like it i mean i feel
yeah no i get it like it's definitely
it's definitely a topic that as a
youtuber you're kind of scared to talk
because because you know a lot of the
people and i know this is so anecdotal
but you know i do see the the line there
and the connection there where i i've me
i've met a lot of youtubers who uh you
know they've uh a few of them have
fallen off now a few of them still do it
whatever but you know they they prided
themselves they one interacted with
their fans and two uh read all the fan
mail and right now wait interacted how
so well okay that's a whole nother thing
yeah right yeah i i don't trust
youtubers who spend all their day like
in their discord interacting with their
community yeah right yes that's one of
the biggest red flags to me as a
youtuber that i don't because i don't
really want i'm just like how do you
find the time to do this because like
you have to find the time basically if
if you're interacting too much with your
community and reading family and stuff
and then doing youtube on top of that
that to me says
you have no time to do anything else in
your life yeah i barely have enough time
to do anything else in my life yeah i
had to like cut this down a lot just to
make it manageable yeah because when i
had my discordance start yeah you know
it can be a very intoxicating feeling to
if you're like oh wow everyone's here
for me yeah look at all these people
wanting to talk to me i'm so popular
i've never had this before you know
because you know you cut back a year or
two before this and i'm the guy who can
you know barely get four people to turn
up to a [ __ ] event yeah you know what
i mean like yeah so you kind of get
intoxicated on this like almost
narcissistic tendency of the fact that
you love the fact that everyone wants to
talk to you right yeah and that everyone
wants to come for you and again it's
it's not i'm not trying to slate the
viewers or i'm trying to it's completely
different from my discord
i'm a [ __ ] clown in my discord
this is the private verse but even then
okay yeah even though your your discord
is private right yeah
they they still want your time yeah
right and so that's a that's a really
difficult juggling act because you have
to separate yourself to a certain extent
to be able to you know have a healthy
relationship with it yeah because
you know i could talk about this forever
but like there's there's differences
audiences
because there's a whole other thing
between the difference between male
audiences and some female audience yeah
oh god yeah yeah yeah um and they have
totally different things but yeah okay
going back to the whole uh
discord and interacting and stuff so
yeah there's two kind of interacting
there's reading fan mail and all that
where to me reading the whole fan mail
thing is a very one-sided um
thank you thank you very much ashley a
one-sided
the trash
you know
i i don't know i just sat there and i
thought man it's so hard to bring up
talking about the fact that you don't
read fan mail
and not sound like wait what got you
onto this like thought process like like
did something happen because i was just
thinking back and i had like this like
uh this you know that moment of
realization you get in the movies yeah
and i've thought about this a lot um and
i just remember this this like i said i
remember the situation with this
youtuber uh who i had kind of a weird
interaction with i didn't really like
him i always thought it was quite
strange yeah
and one thing that uh he did that was
just bizarre is that he's one of those
youtubers who made like 500 parts of
opening fan mail yeah and on one part i
understand because i did this because
for a little while i felt guilty that
people were selling this stuff
and they weren't getting to see my
reaction to their stuff right but also
once once i got three episodes into
doing this yeah i realized
okay well there's only so many different
ways i can react to these fan mail yeah
you know what i mean like there's you
know
and some of these stories that people
would send you are so
deep and really intense you know and and
not not to take away from any of them
but some of them would be really [ __ ]
deep yeah like and i think if they're
especially it feels good to like share
that on video feels one it feels weird
to share that on camera and also
you know as a youtuber i'm thinking
when they wrote this story out you know
what did they want from me
what did they what did they expect when
they wrote this story
what kind of response did they want and
also you know is it impractical for me
to
write back now occasionally i'm
saying this now i'm probably gonna never
do this again because i
this is probably gonna be because i want
people to take advantage of this yeah
occasionally when people did send me
like really uh touching things to my
email you know or very like emotional
things i would reply and just be like
hey man keep your head up or whatever
yeah yeah yeah you know i would do that
because but i didn't want to advertise
that i was doing that because i didn't
want people to think that if they sent
me a sob story i would reply being like
hey champ pick yourself up you know yeah
here's a 10 bucks [ __ ] off yeah
what i mean but you know you didn't want
to like sell yourself as like the
therapist right yeah no because you know
i when when you start doing the the fan
mail stuff more often than not i find
that it does come to that
because that's just how it is you know
people realize you respond people start
taking advantage of that